One, I believe in God,
I know some people don't,
many people who don't nonetheless believe
in something greater than themselves.
I believe that, if you believe in
something greater than yourself,
that your life will be more full and
productive.
So I believe in God, and
by the way, in believing in God,
I believe therefore we
are all His children.
And I believe that God loves all of us,
and
I believe He loves us as you
would love your children.
Some are doing naughty things, some are
doing nice things, but you love them all.
And I believe that I will be measured,
and you will be measured.
Based upon what you have done for
your fellow children of God, and
that means your spouse, your children and
your community more broadly.
So that's a big part of
what's important to me,
which are the people
around me that I care for.
The person I care for most of the life
is my wife, we met in high school,
I love her passionately.
She is the most important person in my
life, if I could do anything on any day,
it would be to be with her.
That's what I enjoy most in life.
Close thereafter is to be with my kids, my
boys and their wives and now 23 grandkids.
The greatest joy I have in
life is being with them.
Sitting around in the backyard or at
a beach, just being with my grandkids and
family is the greatest source of happiness
and the most important thing to me.
Coming beyond that is a circle which
includes my church, my congregation,
the people I know at church and
my sense of service to them.
Service in the broadest sense,
giving back in the sense of caring for
people around me.
Follows from that belief in
something bigger than myself.
I happen to belief that the currency in
life, is the people that you love and
that care for you.
The friends you have, most of what
you've learned here you'll forget.
The people you've met here you'll
remember the rest of your life.
And will form a big part
of your of your wealth.
That's your balance sheet when life is
over, who loves you and you love, and
who are your friends and
how close are they to you.
So, what's the most important thing to me?
My God, my wife, my kids, and
my fellow human beings and
I participate and
engage with people at large.
Through campaigns, through speeches,
through serving at charities,
in all sorts of ways and the rewards
that come back are rewards in people.
In friendship, in love, and that's
what makes the most impact in my life.